16 okay so it's March Madness time and
you'll remember here on Good Day Las
Vegas last year we highlighted the best
pizza places across town pizza is so
important so we profiled the final four
here on good day of course in the end
only one could win now we have the
winner once again Dom DeMarco's pizza
here we've got the owner Albert Scalia
and Albert good morning I know you guys
are making up those pizza highs behind
you how are things going for you guys
um we're so excited that you won last
year by the way
oh I'm excited too and we're having a
wonderful time
and the pizza smells delicious I'm
getting hungry early in the morning
smell-o-vision here so don let's talk
about sort of the science of pizza what
makes a good pizza obviously Dom
DeMarco's the the ties to New York City
are well known of course but what makes
a good pizza pie
well it's it's the ingredients
and it's knowing what to do with the
ingredients
so you gotta You Gotta Buy to buy the
best ingredients and you know and you
have to know how to use them see I was
buying average ingredients and I didn't
know what to do with them that was my
first those are my two mistakes that was
your fatal flaw now Albert Sherry swensk
is a is a a patron of your restaurant
many times over and she says you can
tell it's good because your family eats
your food
absolutely absolutely every night at
five o'clock and I miss Sherry
I'm sure she'll be back pretty darn soon
here and finally uh Albert you know we
got basketball coming up March Madness
starts this week uh the pizza moves and
what people can maybe go to Dom DeMarcos
to do to watch some of the basketball
some of your uh your bars there
yeah we'll have all the games on all the
guys 10 large TVs here okay
okay it's plain old cheese so folks take
it from the man who knows thanks Oliver
appreciate it take care of yourself
thank you
oh yeah he's like forget it I'm out of
here they're making pizza I'm eating
pizza oh it is good pizza and they do
have great happy hour so I'm not gonna
lie well this year eight news now wants
to wants to uh know what your favorite
burger spot is last year was all about
pizza this year it's March Madness for
burgers so to make your burger bracket
picks you just click on the best burgers
bracket on the front page of our website
8newsnow.com or you can scan that code
right there on your TV that's uh that'll
take you right to the website where you
can start making your picks I've been
looking over it there are so many spots
there are restaurants and places you
wouldn't even think of that do serve
burgers and you go oh wow I remember
they have a great burger I'm gonna vote
for them so it's 64. right so starting
to start with 64. wow we're gonna
Whittle it all the way down and people
are very territorial about their burgers
the same way we are with pizzas right
absolutely you can be a pizza stop you
can be a burger snob it's all good you
have a favorite burger joint Jerry well
the Slater's 50 50 is pretty cool
it's on the list
that's what Jerry's all about